we're all books are required i'm holding
the book right here that you should all
get the last enforcer outrageous stories
from the life and times of one of the
nba's fiercest competitors and that's a
fact written with frank isola the great
charles oakley here in person on the
rich island show how are you sir good
good to see you thanks for having me
congrats on the book thank you uh i have
been waiting and patiently
to talk to you for quite some time sir
oh already this is a fact um for a
couple of reasons number one
so i'm from staten island new york okay
born in brooklyn raised in staten island
you sir
are one of my favorite new york knicks
of all time thank you i'm glad i could
be here fact fact glad we can meet it in
person the way i the fact i can sit here
and tell you like the the kid from the
80s and the 90s or whatever that i can
look you in the face and say thank you
thank you means honestly i'm getting
like uh
emotional here because what you did with
with uh patrick and the rest of the the
knicks you and with the riley and with
every i mean that was incredible
and that was a long time coming for a
bunch of nick fans yeah i'm sorry we
couldn't win the big one but uh we
competed every night and so a lot of
hard out there yeah i know and so i
guess at the time uh when you were going
through it um what was that like to be
there with patrick and riley in the
garden and it was all that uh what was
that like for you i mean when i first
got there was you know
wasn't great but once we made the
transaction um
we you know got pat riley there with a
whole different mindset this guy won
championships with la mccree magic you
know um he had an identity he brought
some l.a with him and he mix it with new
york toughness
and um
we got it down um
good as we could and you know we showed
a good product on the court every night
you sure did and it just the sense at
the time too i mean you came from
chicago right and you did your work with
jordan and against the bad boys and
the knicks needed to be very honest they
needed someone to put somebody on their
ass you know and that was your job
pretty much right well they called for
the doctor i showed up so
and another name i did i just i came
there like i said like i said when you
move to another house make sure it's
better than the last one
so when i got traded from chicago new
york i tried to make sure i play better
in new york than just did chicago let
them know that they gave it a good piece
but
no new york was a great experience for
me uh it was the big city and
name it twice new york new york that's
right i had a lot of fun there well i
mean i was so much fun watching you and
then you know um before we get deeper
into that
you got the forward of your book written
by michael jordan yeah what was it like
for a rookie out of virginia union to
show up there in chicago jordan already
did what he had done in his first his
rookie season what was that like to be
there stan all back being the coach yeah
well basically my job was to come in and
and thanks jerry cross for drafting me
you know top 10 number one and show him
that uh he made a great choice um come
in
understanding that um he did a good job
scouting me and knew my strength and
weakness i knew my strength for weakness
and so when i brought it to the court i
stayed within myself i didn't try to
come out and compete my score many
points michael jordan uh the next guy i
knew that hey be humble you play the
game stuff come to you when you
understand the game
um
why didn't it work out in chicago with
jordan
when you were there yeah
i said they work out they was had a lot
of forwards and they dropped the horse
and scotty
and they didn't have a center
and they made the transition of trading
me for bill cartwright uh it worked out
i had a great three years
probably my you know i'm not saying my
best but i was up there with you know
double digit points scoring rebound
i guess worked out as an unfortunate way
of me to put it and i apologize i mean
the championship years they occurred you
know obviously like well they won three
years at i left so my thing is i thought
when i got traded in new york i'm going
with bachelorette from georgetown.
disneynet
that wasn't the case uh
it was passing your own body but he left
a lot of soul in georgetown
what's your relationship with jordan
like right now
me yeah uh on the forward i guess it's
so you know
he did the forward something you
probably would never guess he didn't he
didn't he didn't have a copy of the book
so
that showed a lot of respect for me
and you know
knowing that you know knowing being
around him the longer i've been around
here we've been tight close friends for
let me you know so trust me so if
somebody trusts you sometimes
about him doing that just show me he
really really trusts me in-law me
because you know
i think he really did afford for scotty
boy he might be upset with himself
i was gonna ask you did you reach out to
scotty on how to sell a book did you
reach out to him
well i guess he said when you when you
when you aim aim high so he went for the
goat what'd you think uh
i got an opinion but what's your opinion
if you go by stats and go by your body
work it's about to work don't compare to
the top 20 player we played basketball
so it's hard to say he's better michael
jordan to me but that's his opinion
what about everything else he was saying
about what was the times in chicago
about
um anything that was going on there
obviously you weren't there when you
when he was there with chicago and he
was talking about the book but
yes they're talking about you know
racist and
still being racist anything like that
you know you don't know who races these
days it's what's where's the meters it's
a hard to call it don't say racist uh
um
i don't know just i don't look at it but
if you see someone racist you have to be
really detailed paying attention with
every second of the day what are they
doing so i don't know uh
i was there one year with phil i mean he
was coming from the
devil uh the g was doing the deal he uh
what the league was yeah he was the
assistant right assistant right he came
up jake crouch hand-picked him
he came up with doug collins
and
he was just assistant coach you know tex
was there doug was there and um
he was a quiet guy you know
i did some little research on the play
with the knicks and uh you know he was
upcoming coach jerry you know
jerry hit a lot of home runs in that
little era he had with with the bulls he
made a lot of things happen
in a good way they won six rings but
they don't they don't want to talk jerry
up jerry and i hit it you know
she wanted to bounce some of the stuff
back to him that people were saying
about jerry i thought jerry was a nice
guy he drafted me so i have nothing he
traded me he drafted me so i guess i
still have nothing bad to say about him
but uh
he get a lot of bad rap
from people you know they said he wanted
a lot of credit i mean my thing is jerry
put the team together john jerry
rashford paid the team mates so with
scotty contract michael jordan contract
came up it went up to jerry of jerry
ryan stuff the owner
and you know he was a little tight you
know he got one pocket
and one pair of pants so you know he's
kind of tight
charles oakley here on the rich eisen
show the last enforcer checking out
where all books are sold okay
um i used to be a knick fan okay okay
uh i stopped being a knick fan that
night where you were taken out of
madison square garden okay i just i
can't i can't root for that team anymore
yeah
and
um i i was so angry yeah so angry
to see you
taken out by madison square garden
security
what the hell happened that night it was
a hit
that's all i can say
i was there for maybe seven minutes i
got there with me me and three other
guys we walked down the steps
and um i went to the thurman monsoon
foundation dinner the night before okay
so i did that three or four times you
know
and uh the next the guy said you're
going to the game i said no he said we
got extra tickets outside go with
charles i met him across the street from
the guard we come in down the steps i
sit down girl come ask me what you want
to drink i said i want a pepsi some
popcorns
by the time she bring them back in two
minutes i was there about eight minutes
and then like saying there was eight
guys surrounding me
like
you got to leave i'm like for what
i have a ticket you got to leave and i
said i'm not leaving then they started
grabbing on me so don't grab on me and i
said if you watch this you can hear all
loud and clear and they saying one thing
happened i slipped down and failed and a
few more guys came and they took me to
the back
next thing i know down there they put
the handcuffs on me
handcuffed you handcuffs so
okay before the before we get to that so
at any point in time
you know when they came
to grab you and took you did did dolan
ever james dolan the owner of new york
did he ever look in your direction did
he just looking back
he saw what was going on he was a hit
because why we watched the tape i don't
know because i don't dance to his music
he like uh i like rick james he like
flies sandstone i like uh luther he like
uh patty bail but my thing was he likes
jd in the straight shot actually
they throw cans at them
but no
so we watched the tape
yeah and you can see like it was a
timeout or something security guard go
over there and talk to him
[Music]
so after the timeout he go back to the
stand to the station
then
he then something that happened a dead
ball filed he walked over there
and talked to him again security guard
talked to him
so he can go back to stand behind the
bench then
you can see him in the in the take we
got he given the guy's signal he's like
go go go i mean he's like okay
yeah go go go go speak to him or go what
have you like to do he wanted why does
he want you out of there like what
i don't know he don't he don't like me
because he said i said something in the
paper but he's trying to tell in the
court that i hollered at him i'm like
john mcenroe sitting right here if you
go how am i hollered at you in 20 000
people
i ain't like i came to the game early
walked past a hey big head no
i come in he went straight to my seat
and he just he just got it out for me so
after that happened so basically they
take me downstairs with the customer
might go to the precinct that i just
said that happened
here come phil jackson oh what happened
what happened ask your boss
then world wars come like i got you mj
on the phone i'm handcuffed
i mean put him on speaker so
hold on a second
so all right
phil
jackson uh went to the police precinct
no he came from a seat okay
to the back of the arena where you are
now being held in handcuffs yeah in
madison square garden yeah
and he's like what's and so
what happened next he like what's going
on i said that's your boss and then
world wide west coming i got michael
jordan on the phone i said i'm
handcuffed i said put him on speaker you
know it was just funny that way i said
it but
so then they you know i i said get these
damn handcuffs off me i just started
cussing and then next thing you know
they put me in you know taking me across
the street
so i get there they take the handcuffs
off
and they like what happens it's just
crazy incident they say you gonna send
me they ordered me a pizza so i went
back to the state i went in the sale you
were in a cell that night yeah i mean i
heard that but i i i can't
how did jordan get on the phone
uh world west had called him and feels i
guess so what did jordan say i didn't
get a chance to talk to him
i told him
i said something funny i said i said
tell me come and get me
i'm like
talk come and get me
so
about 12 30 1 o'clock they let me out
two guys from long island i know he's a
cop another guy like a guy from the
hedge fund group
they came and got me out
and um
i did the interview that night was just
it was just crazy i mean my thing is i
had never met him before his dad i met
they're from cleveland i'm from
cleveland dolan yeah the family they
grew up like five minutes for me in
cleveland
so
well in your book there's a an account
about you and dolan during an nba
all-star weekend in new orleans prior is
that where that's the front this is my
place
so we're in new orleans i think it's
2014 2017 14. yeah 2014 we're in new
orleans
i went lebron the whole crew because
they from cleveland
and uh we were just in that room just
messing around so he'll come worry about
wes he walked from out the back
you know something happened with that
click like rich paul and wes which paul
is from cleveland so some of that
happened so he don't he don't speak the
west at all
so
lebron being a pro he'd speak to him
maybe whatever so he's oh i'm back there
with i said i'm in the back with uh with
the guy from nick i said who he said i'm
a donor come and meet him that's okay
so me and my friend jacob we walk in the
back this is james dolan yeah
and you had never met him never met him
this is just before in in new orleans
huh but this is well
okay so i'm walking back with wes he
said uh mr dolan this is mr oakley he
said i'm at him this is like me saying
he don't turn around nothing i met him
so i'm like what's going on
said he mentioned his man ain't that me
so my mind was should i hit him in the
head
should i hit him in the head
i i mean so
i'm like man you brought me back here he
said he met he didn't meet me man i mean
i'm a lie about i met him like
won't he just be a gentleman anyway just
sat up and said how are you doing miss
oakley
and so my guy with me like man he's kind
of rude right now so yeah
he don't he must he don't like me so
it's just it's just i don't know
a small man complex uh you know i don't
know what his problem is but he do the
same thing over always with people i
mean
if you check his record out he got a lot
of incidents on it by dealing with he
don't deal with people good well charles
oakley i i i saw this and i'm like i
can't i can't root for this team anymore
i just i can't i just can't i can see if
i want to do so i mean i wouldn't even i
was sitting behind him i ain't i can see
if i walk in front of him so he's big
head or you know just you know what i'm
saying i didn't i wasn't like four rows
then he tells him i was sent two clothes
to him somebody said you knew what you
said no i didn't i didn't know where the
guys had the tickets at i mean
i've been to many games and bought
tickets and sit three or four rows but i
don't know he just had that you
shouldn't matter you're charles oakley
you're charles oakley you're a part of
one of the greatest times in the history
of the new york times
and you know and and the owner of the
new york knicks should welcome the you
like is it because you were critical of
him and the team
did nothing i mean he just uh he's a
control freak
he's a real big control freak so
basic like guys who work for him they
can't do interviews with people besides
they have to know what the course is
he's just a controlled thing he's real
controlling you have no idea charles i
mean you guys could tell him right like
uh there's something here called the
dolan wormhole okay it's like the
gravitational force in the universe any
time this man's name comes up i can't i
get pulled right in i get so livid and
he starts to shake yeah yeah
but i don't know my thing is like i can
see you like
if i would have said i was a man but i
would have told everybody like everybody
came to my rescue but i did if i was
wrong i would stood up in times square
somewhere in central park and just had a
press come like
i was wrong i said something to this guy
he said nothing to him that's what make
it so bad
you know
he just he just had it out for me so
what's the future is there anyone yeah
this is what happened after that a week
about a week later so michael jordan
commissioned
myself
so we got
together oh
i'll retire your jersey come we played
indiana about two weeks you can come sit
beside i'm like
no no this one will happen so they had
they had a bowling event this night he
said
well you can walk into bowling with me
and make everybody see us together i'm
like are you see what just happened my
family singing this and you handcuffs
and you treat me like a runaway whatever
back in the old days and you want me to
come sit beside you
all right then he went from that to like
in two weeks we played the pesos you can
come we have everything
red carpet i'm like
you just don't you're guilty right there
why you want to do all this for me now
if you ain't if if if you know if you're
not wrong
so there is no future there huh there's
no future there there's no i don't know
i don't wait to see yeah but you know
what did ewing have to say about all
this
well this hap that happened 2017 what 17
he just said so about five months ago
nothing
i played with him 10 years
i had his back
they offered him a daily job about seven
years ago i spoke how are you off a guy
who played for you 15 years of d league
job
but
you know he that hurt me when he didn't
speak up for me
i mean if i know somebody play
especially in sports you can play 10
years with somebody you should be able
to know them and know what they stand
for and he didn't he didn't do that
he didn't put his big boy pants on
charles oakley here uh on the rich eisen
show some other uh aspects of this book
to hit here um
uh you knew that lebron was going to
cleveland uh was going to leave
cleveland and go to miami before his
then yep
a year before how did you know that um
that season before he went
um
going to that season they played orlando
and then went to miami for like a
back-to-back game
so
i you know from cleveland so i um
told him i was going to be in miami he
said well come hang out i mean orlando
he said come hang out we're going to
dinner that i moved to the steakhouse
and we're just talking having fun it's
enough
he said man
i'm going to miami next year
i said really yo
so
the next the next day we go to the game
orlando
i was driving so they flew to miami that
after the game so i drove the next day
and i told patreon i was coming to the
game he left me two tickets i said i
need to talk to you about something
he said all right you know we go to my
office i have time to talk you know
so he went in there
you know
[Music]
i said
you i don't know if you know or not
somebody think about coming here
is it really
he said who
i said well you might be playing against
him tonight
matter of fact you are
he said no okay
so
one thing led to another
the next year that next summer
in miami
damn
yeah
it's the only way i can respond to that
so
all right so you gave riley a little
heads up that this
you know because yeah
i told lebron i told him
okay and
how much longer do you think lebron's
going to play
i don't know what's your production
for the legos somebody else they don't
get this situation straight now with
basketball
you know out here now it's just the clip
was bad they bad
you can't be bad with lebron on your
team that's what cleveland had lebron
they were never bad
you know he just every time he went to
miami came out of the cleveland he made
a difference they was only winning 25 26
games he take him from 25 to 50 55. it's
just i don't know why the kneeling is
moving here somebody's holding him back
because
like he said he needs shooters on the
outside but
it's more in shoot energy no rotation
i mean they got too many guys just
looking at the rim well anthony davis
has got to get healthy right yeah but
anthony
he ain't
he been at the davis since the the
bubble
i mean they won the championship with
him he's one of them guys he looks so
pretty playing
but he's still hurt
a bentley with no gas and you can't run
it
um
so you think he's
thinking again of departing i mean
what's your two cents on that you're
gonna settle for this loser and they and
who do they have the trade beside
anthony david i mean king trade
westbrook can get nothing
unless you can
and you can trade wrestle to get defense
maybe and you know just limit the guys
who own your offense because i mean
everybody you see that they need the
ball
and that's
i mean you got almost four hall of
famers on that team and they lose barely
beating bad teams you still had three
hall of fame started dwight howard
westbrook and lebron
and carmella election of the business
four
so
but but he's going to play until i guess
his son comes in here right i mean
that's not the thing
i mean
if he can't move the needle
past 500 i don't you know i mean another
year is i don't see that i mean he might
not he might try to hold on but
he don't want to just be at the plan
just as i play 82 80 75 games and go
home he won't
his goal is to win a championship
um
before i let you go who's the guy today
that mirrors your game the most would
you say charles oakley
who would be that person thank you i
don't that role is not in nba right now
no more
i don't see that i don't
you know draymond was a point forward um
set picks make stuff and college look
great every night and doing the hustle
stuff
uh
maybe you know
draymond maybe just better ball handle
but overall just
with the force or shutting down the pain
i mean dre might do check centers at six
um
centers to be 16 and getting away with
it he do a lot of filing they don't
golden state is like what the
boston used to be they let you get away
with other stuff some teams don't get
away with
when you start winning you get that wit
winning
and sometimes like these teams who used
to win and think they get no you ain't
getting called westbrook you're not
getting called you take your time you're
gonna make your layup
that's it that's how it is now
who would you relish
if you were back in the nba right now
charles who would you relish putting on
his ass the most
if you were back in the league right now
who would you relish would say like i
would i would
just one more time just
it's like a freeway now everybody's
going down the paint i know that
but if you were standing there
like you'd say i would
i'd like to
put that guy on his ass
right now so basin is in a question like
this it's somebody who cry a lot
so
so guys i see crowd a lot who got the
ball in hands a lot mm-hmm
uh
james hardly flopped a lot and he's a
big body but i want you know he he goes
to the hole like it ain't nothing but
see now he from the west coast to the
east he's not getting them bailouts no
more in the east like he got in west
so he's not playing that well it's a
different i tell everybody in the past
it's a different plan than easton
playing west most guys can play in the
west game play in the east
and so
uh but it's like i said it's like a
freeway you know you you like get your
easy pass going through
the easy pass i love that uh all right
charles this is great i literally could
talk to you for like two hours um
congrats on the book thank you and
let's do this more often i'd love to i
really would love it um and one other
guy's name i didn't bring up uh is
anthony mason listen i mean may he rest
in peace
i mean that's my guy right that's my god
we did a lot together in new york
we was the blues brothers uh
the real blue it's the mother blue
brother they fake them but we were the
real blue brothers uh we did a lot
together i mean there was this city i
came in they embraced me like you know
when it came to the team he just totally
self-made like nobody saw him coming i
mean what he became and how terrific
i mean what he became in new york city
just
a big wide body the two of you guys just
putting everybody
down you know
we had we just need a little more
shooting
well i mean and i loved starks too yeah
you know just a little more what
happened that night
and usually
i know what can you say i know i know
man and i would have been great to have
you lift the championship so all right
last one
so i'm not coming back as a fan until
you come back okay
all right we're sticking together i know
we just talked about blues brothers but
i'm not okay all right all right you
come back i come back i'll let you know
for sure
all right because you get the news
before anyone i promise
because you can tell him i'm i'm serious
about this you have no idea look at the
news i have no idea a lot of people like
oh go back and get the book
no i can't give that much credit
they asked are you talking about him in
the book i said about a half a page
you know i can't give no full page he
ain't worth a full page
[Laughter]
i'm serious yeah charles this man loses
he just james dolan sends him to a fit
of rage i grew up in madison square
garden the noise of the garden gets me
going when the pandemic and the fans
came back in and i heard what the garden
sounded like i'm like that's the noise
that's the same stuff okay and that's
what i love and so and and i see julius
randle who i respect oh it's weird
seeing him in bernard king's number but
just like seeing him do his thing and rj
barrett and i do like the coach and i
get into it and think of you and i'm
like i can't do it why he won't retire
bernard king number
he's in the hall of fame what are you
waiting on
i don't know because that's the uh
that's my guy
bernard king is one of the greatest
players
ever
yes and what he and it was a damn shame
although it was his knee injury that got
the knicks high enough that they could
get the the
yes that they had
you know the shot at patrick uh but the
fact that bernard and patrick played
with each other just as passing ships is
one of my
yeah but he should be tired bernard
number but one time i guess when mello
was there
something happened and bernard posted
something
he made bernard take it down off his
twitter account
all right i'm not coming back
okay okay all right two of us all right
all right
the two of us together all right there
we go charles hulk is gonna let me know
the last enforcer uh with frank isola
where all books can be uh acquired
charles oakley right here on the rich
eisen show thank you thank you you bet
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here